how's it going bros my name is PewDiePie
epic gamer here today we're playing a
game we're gonna figure out which one of
these five gamers it's the actual fake
gamer that's right I genuinely think I'm
good at this I can tell whenever I'm
talking to people they know I do gaming
and they're like oh yeah no I'm gamer
two I'm totally like we're just the same
no you're not don't even try I love
watching my brother play but then you're
not a gamer well I love playing on my
foot that you're not a gamer oh I love
playing on my xbox not a gamer oh I love
speedrunning not a gamer just pathetic
also I said this before but I remember
back in my day when I was young I
couldn't tell people I was a gamer I
would get judged at all pathetic you can
bait you play games you nerd that's what
it was like in Sweden we had to hide it
I was a minority I was a let me finish
sentence I was a minority of people
that's play video games but we're still
cool yeah I'll call myself cool I don't
care if that sounds cringe because there
was the genuine people that were just
like nerds gamers and then there was
this minority of the finest specimen I
should stop talking
alright the point is I walked so you can
run now people are faking being gamers
to pretend pathetic anyway start the
video let's go this is Jubilee five
gamers versus one fake gamer and we can
play along I'm so excited
what is that this is tag hanging out
alright this guy is definitely a gamer
because he has an unfunny shirt that one
thing gamers love it's unfunny shirts
they've just kicked him
I know a couple people watching this
right now and they're looking down like
I got damnit alright he's right
we brought together six gamers I'm a
gamer I'm a game
sorry what ever hear a woman say they're
a gamer I it makes me laugh now in the
game I'm Joe a gamer I am a gamer I'm a
giver one is a liar
if the group discovered who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize oh they get
money hey so there's incentive to
actually do well well I never actually
watched these I know they do a ton of
them I just wanted to see if I can spot
a game of rid of liar survives they win
the entire prize what so you're highly
incentivized to maybe do a little like
research and stuff cuz do they know what
topic they're gonna pretend to be surely
they do they're gonna be the whole unit
you might want to like come up with some
ideas interesting quick question if
you're a real gamer what is it pose
called
oh I trust that's some gamer but I trust
you applesauce I trust let's let's gauge
the reaction of the other people here
look at that guy see he's like that's a
window shut down face he has no idea
he's either a terrible gamer or not a
gamer at all
we have nothing happening here this guy
just looks confused she's definitely a
gamer because she's trying really hard
to prove that she's a gamer I trust wait
what his theme ideas I love blood 3000
if he's not a gamer he's a [ __ ]
weirdo what absolute unit with a picture
of a buff community male 3 5 7 this all
sound really shitty made up I'm gonna
mess between the flower girl if I see
chickens out here with a picture of
Lucifer all right this guy's safe he's
safe I guess right now I'm leaning
between the people on the light okay see
though I'm mainly paid over
my league and pop G okay okay oh I'm
ohso not a gamer I'm just kidding I'm
like very into simulation games I play a
lot of like The Sims like 90s horror
stuffs right now I'm playing haunting
just saying do you guys I guess everyone
else is not a gamer then keep they don't
know haunting oh that that game yeah so
what happens now so this is followers
vote so they think hem and then oh
really
people think him interesting he gets
NOLA thin two hundred rides and Jessica
another time yeah 30 seconds to give a
case for themselves
what is this okay so if any of you play
the least thing you know right yeah yeah
I know about the blue in the blue in the
right truck yeah and those what the [ __ ]
that's what you got out of they get that
game they got trucks in it you know that
was this case I proved gamer all right
so like the Slender games to have like a
blue truck and the red truck so I rest
my case
what oh you know what you know what's a
great way to figure out if someone's a
fake gamer ask them like rate your
favorite Dark Souls games or but or just
souls games in general and see what what
do they do and if you peek Dark Souls 2
at the top you just throw them out of
there just like punch them in the face
that's not I would do it no it's just
very good when it comes to like being
under pressure
I dunno my League of Legends I know my
job what role do you play in League of
Legends and what's your favorite
champions Oh ad carry and ash usually I
also like jinx okay so I tend to play
those a lot of farming for turrets to a
lot of farming oh yeah it's so the point
of the game I understand
turrets turrets remember turret you what
is space ring are you master at best
okay all right
she did redeem herself a little bit at
the end fair fair all right
[Music]
Wow she went out that is so sexy they're
basically all saying women can't game
which I would never say cuz that's bad
to say that's the original question I
asked before where I said what's
everyone's favorite video games how
about we just go around saying like when
you first play that games are you
Kingdom Hearts is my favorite video game
ever like a huge part my life I love
that game store and reviews my favorite
I even go through this is I believe this
guy because anyone that has Kingdom
Hearts as their favorite game cannot
shut the [ __ ] up about it
so I believe him he's under percent
clear no I said much I don't know much
about it you know the Wiis and why I got
to League was because of my friends from
another game we're all transitioning
over to League and then ever since then
I've just been playing that with my
girlfriend and their cousins well my
friend this guy is a gamer and has a
girlfriend
[Music]
mmm-hmm alright you just grow some
suspicious pointers it is pokemon
emerald like I've been playing emeralds
it's a little kid I remember I I can't
really see this guy just being like ah
video games I don't really have time for
that I just like to read a nice book I
can't really picture the t-shirt is such
a giveaway that I hate 7% clear so far
this guy in this guy is clear it took me
seven years to beat battle dome and I'm
are being so excited that I what the
hell is battle dome that's not even a
game that's a TV show you dumbass that's
a cool TV show battle dome game Pokemon
it took him seven years to beat battle
dome the frantic pinball battle game I
respect that I respect that hold up the
camera immediately and started taking
pictures and posting it everywhere just
huge moment right there okay for me my
favorite game would probably be Paper
Mario the very first time I saw the game
my brother played it and I loved it my
favorite game is until Paper Mario is
also a fair like that's another Kingdom
Hearts type of game that people grew up
on so I believe that that's her favorite
game and my favorite
until dawn which we started playing in
college my friend Bree was playing it
and her he started playing it in college
his favorite game is until dawn all
right if he's a gamer he's got no
respect for me it's a good game don't
get me wrong but favorite game
absolutely not absolutely not that's
disgusting
no gamer respect at all favorite game
until dawn see I think this is this is
it instead maybe I'm not so good at
knots Nate I'd sniffing out the gamer
but I'm good at judging people from
their tasting video games if you can't
even count you can't even count I don't
see anyone playing on till dawn more
than like five times after that it's
like wait why the [ __ ] would you can't
even count I'm smelling [ __ ]
reference time okay yeah so your first
run who died I don't know that I don't
remember that but my memory is terrible
but I do remember some very thick big
jump scares in the game does that save
me oh god I wish I whenever this is
lying game I'm terrible at lying
basically people always suspect it's me
for some reason people suspect I do bad
things
I'll tell upon who dies first well I
know who the main character is it's the
guy from robot yeah so he doesn't die
first
I mean if it's his favorite game and
he's played it countless times he should
know that that's pretty smart of her to
ask actually I like like the first
person who died I think can't you change
who the first person is advice isn't
that up to you isn't that the point of
the game Veronica Veronica until dawn
dude there's no Veronica
there's no Veronica I played it
countless times
[Music]
well I can tell you what it's like it's
not a bad creature you know these are
all gamers because they just can't
handle any confrontation here like this
girl who's clearly like way more alpha
than all of them I did try to like
button like hey let's move it but it was
it was like a wall I guess like if I was
there I wouldn't be able to tell ya
there's no Veronica honestly my mind
went blank when she asked me about like
Oh like about a character or something
like I couldn't think of a character's
names I could only think like the actors
and actresses so I said Veronica there's
no there's no actor called Veronica
either ah just a little shred of thought
of me thinking you know what don't do
that don't make that hand saying women
are a lot alike moon should not be
allowed to make that hand sign I don't
appreciate that like it's hard being put
on the spot
she split she was black hair short black
hair she has a little more right here
brown eyes
she's like the t1 he's like oh like
she's like the asian girl yeah who is
the Asian girl in untold on all right
let's see it yeah Nicole Blum all right
it's Veronica like I don't know why even
sounds like he's lying they totally fire
him
is Mike Josh okay hayden Panettiere her
name is Jim damn what a memory named
Jessica no you said the Asian what was
away she said Veronica what a gaming
metaphor right here the whole squad
standing behind a woman calling out a
fake why aren't they helping her you all
win money right oh she never had a
gameboy advance
oh who oh you know what it's probably
her okay nut okay good yes not even know
okay so I don't believe knowledge I know
you do Vegard vel'koz and my life okay
so you're like mid yeah okay what she
just said
I play Lux Soraka Sona and Annie and
give some more info yeah how about okay
what what is the last name you guys
bought like the latest one you just
bought
last game that I bought you may have to
come back to that because I bought a
game no oil
I have Humble Bundle so I get like a
bundle of games like every month do you
don't read the last game you got light
from the Humble Bundle the last game I
got from the Humble Bundle
see I got sleigh the spire and which was
like that's very specific
check this recent month yet yeah slay
the spire I got that one
wait what you they voted her out oh you
can't read these guys vote her out after
this game see hey all right let's see
you it is it's definitely the guy that
looks like a school and the guy on the
light I know
[Applause]
they voted her out after she discovered
him that money so they get the money and
not her I guess next time learn the
names of characters better yeah I should
not have been that hard why did you pick
a game like that where you can literally
just be like really this person this
president this person it's so easy and
we want an episode where everyone is the
mole but no one knows that's pretty
funny alright so that was five gamers
versus one fake gamers did you get it
right let me know in the comments thanks
to jewbilee for landing we react on
their videos very fun to watch I enjoyed
this let me know if you did as well
smash like if you did check out the
merch hook this merch in the gap and I
see you guys tomorrow
hey door subscribe subscribe now do it
click it you know what's big peepees do
they play PewDiePie's pixel ings of
course
pixal ings is a creature collecting game
I'm the primary shareholder over a
Brazilian players have downloaded and
it's got a perfect score it's safe to
say it's the most popular game of all
time
PewDiePie pixel aims its awesome deal
with it build with it
[Music]
you